Нове футбольне поле,
кабінет інформатики з 3D принтером,
інтерактивна дошка та нові меблі для наймолодших учнів.
Директор сільської школи в селі Новаки на Полтавщині
Андрій Рудь не натішиться останніми досягненнями.
59-річний чоловік вже понад 30 років на цій посаді.
Утім, лише після реформи децентралізації та створення ОТГ відчув реальні зміни.
Щороку в межах 200-300 тисяч ОТГ нам виділяє,
щоб створити освітнє середовище,
яке б відповідало вимогам МОЗ та МОН.
Засульська ОТГ, до якої входить село Новаки,
була однією з перших добровільно створених в Україні громад.
Вибори тут відбулися ще в грудні 2016 року.
Голова ОТГ Сергій Бондаренко, згадує, що початок був важким,
люди боялися змін і на його пропозицію об'єднатися одразу всім Лубенським районом
відгукнулася лише половина сіл. З них і створили ОТГ.
Білий колір - це території адміністративної одиниці Лубенський район,
різними кольорами - це наші старостати, які входять у Засульську об'єднану громаду.
Але так трапилося, що ми
запропонували всім, розіслали свої пропозиції.
Хто відгукнувся на нашу пропозицію, ви бачите на цій карті.
Хто, як кажуть,заховав голову в пісок
або не скористався цією можливістю,
залишилися поза межами, в тому числі й місто Лубни.
Добровільне створення громад розпочалося п'ять років тому.
За цей час в Україні сформовано понад тисячу ОТГ.
Вони покривають 90 відсотків території України.
Це високі показники, але цього не достатньо,
аби звітувати про завершення реформи децентралізації.
А до місцевих виборів, які відбудуться вже цієї осені,
вся територія України має бути поділена на громади.
Тож, владавключила "турборежим"
і змінила закон "Про добровільне об'єднання територіальних громад".
Згідно зі змінами, обласні адміністрації отримали повноваження
доукомплектовувати чи ліквідовувати ОТГ.
Це викликало невдоволення низки громад, які вже успішно об'єдналися і працювали.
За підрахунками Асоціації ОТГ, згідно з перспективними планами уряду,
ліквідуються близько 120 громад.
Незгодні ОТГ протестували під Кабміном,
а нині захищають своє право на добровільне об'єднання в судах.
Головне - це довіра людей. Якщо люди захотіли працювати
в громаді N,
вони визначили собі територію, вони з ними порадилися, пройшли вибори
і все зробили, то треба дати людям можливість працювати і їх підтримувати.
Якщо хтось у високому кабінеті вирішив, що це неправильно_
то, звичайно, у людей природно з’являється протест.
У профільному міністерстві протестувальників вислухали,
однак на поступки йти не збираються.
Чому так, пояснює радник Міністра розвитку громад  Іван Лукеря.
Він уточнює, що йдеться не про ліквідацію громад, а радше про їхнє укрупнення.
Адже чимало ОТГ об’єднувались, як хотіли
і не відповідають так званим мінімальним критеріям спроможності.
З 2015 року наголошувалося, що ви можете об'єднуватися скільки завгодно.
Але для того, щоб бути спроможними,
ви маєте об'єднатися в межах перспективного плану.
Бо це ж не тільки право на об'єднання.
Після цього має бути реальна здатність управляти.
Наприклад, у нас є місто - велика спроможна громада.
Біля неї створюється межа в межу
маленька невеличка сільська громада на 1400 людей.
То звичайно, правильніше прийняти рішення
про об'єднання цієї невеличкої громади з більшою.
Окрім того, чимало невеликих громад були штучно створені місцевими бізнесменами
для власної вигоди, каже автор реформи з децентралізації
та народний депутат Верховної Ради восьмого скликання Юрій Ганущак.
Їх тепер також укрупнено. Хоча, зізнається, не всіх "феодалів" вдалося побороти.
Є, звичайно, випадки смертельні,
коли феодалізм переміг в окремо взятій області.Приміром, у Чернівецькій.
Це знаменитий випадок із Сокринянською громадою,
коли місцевий "князь" сказав: я нарізаю, як я хочу.
І вже зі створеної громади
Новодністровської...  три села забрав.
І обласна державна адміністрація під ним лежить, і Кабмін під ним лежить.
Тим часом радник Міністра розвитку громад звітує:
понад 800 ОТГ не мають претензій до уряду.
Щодо деяких незадоволених громад, зокрема Засульсьої,
то Лукеря називає її винятком.
У міністерстві не сумніваються у її спроможності,
хоча критикують за те, що від початку створення ініціатори об’єднання
проігнорували рекомендовані урядом перспективні плани,
зокрема щодо географічного розташування ОТГ.
Можливо, у випадку Засульської ОТГ треба було шукати компроміс,
щоб частину території віддати місту Лубни, щоб не робити кільце,
а зберегти свою громаду.
Активніше працювати з обласною адміністрацією, щоб знайти рішення.
Голова Засульської ОТГ запевняє, що працювали ще й як активно,
показує стоси паперів.
Це листування з чиновниками різних інстанцій: від обласної адміністрації до Офісу президента.
У відповідь - лише відписки.
Відповідь ОДА:
необхідно врахувати те, що в рамках правового поля та діючого законодавства
відсутній будь-який варіант, окрім приєднання Засулля до Лубен.
Для Засульської ОТГ таке укрупнення означає втратити
всі досягнення децентралізації останніх років.
За цей час громаді довелося піти на чимало непопулярних кроків,
зокрема закрити недоукомплектовані школи: з 12 залишилося 7.
Оптимізували заклади медицини.
Вдалося збільшити бюджет громади і завдяки цьому поліпшити матеріальну базу шкіл,
фінансувати ті галузі, на які раніше не вистачало коштів:
почали працювати різноманітні гуртки, відкрили бібліотеки,
започаткували фестивалі, почали розробляти туристичні маршрути між селами.
Планів чимало… Але тепер, кажуть, вся робота зводиться нанівець.
Адже доведеться знову проходити весь шлях спочатку:
інфраструктура 46-тисячного міста Лубни
аж ніяк не вписується в життя сільської громади
Тож, в Засуллі вважають, що значно доцільніше було би об'єднати Лубни
та інші ще не реформовані села в окрему ОТГ.
Усі ми говоримо, що громаду треба зберегти.
Маючи такі досягнення за три роки - те, що ми могли зробити з нуля,
і похоронити всі ці досягнення… Це буде неправильно щодо всіх цих людей.
Захищати себе в суді громада не планує, адже переконані,
що там не будуть призупиняти рішення Кабміну.
Єдиний вихід - це продовжувати шукати порозуміння з обласними чиновниками
та профільним міністерством.
Хоча часу залишилося вкрай мало.
Вже наприкінці червня Верховна Рада має розглянути постанову уряду
та затвердити територіальні межі всіх громад в Україні.
А восени, після місцевих виборів, уряд може прозвітувати
про успішне завершення першого етапу реформи децентралізації.